today's that G report says there is no
evidence that politics played a role in
Jim Comey's actions in 2016 and they
expect you to believe that because they
believe you're stupid but it is clear a
lot of people in his life were deeply
hostile to Donald Trump and now we know
the FBI was filled with the same kinds
of people
today's report reveals even more text
messages to and from Peter struck and
his girlfriend Lisa page including this
damning exchange from August of 2016
Paige texted Strock quote trump's not
ever going to become president right
right stocks reply quote no no he won't
we'll stop it strike and Paige aren't
alone either Thanks today's report we
know at least one other FBI official was
militantly anti-trump at his outlook
mark Stein is an author and columnist he
joins us tonight mark of all the many
quotes in here here are my two favorite
because they reveal so much about the
underlying assumptions of the FBI so
here you have Peter Strax and to his
girlfriend quote just went to a southern
Virginia Walmart I could smell the Trump
supporting and then this on election
night from an FBI employee Trump
supporters are all poor to middle-class
uneducated lazy pieces of human feces
that think he will magically grant them
jobs for doing nothing they probably
didn't watch the debates aren't educated
on his policies and are stupidly wrapped
up in as unmerited enthusiasm these
people these FBI employees see
themselves as members of the ruling
class looking down their noses at the
country they're supposed to be serving
what does that tell you right well it's
absolutely extraordinary this is the
section chief of the FBI's counter
espionage Division and he sounds like
some ranting idiot and what's
interesting to me about this is that the
bias only goes one way you can bet that
if there had been one single email from
any FBI or Department of Justice figure
saying oh you know yeah I'm a bit sick
of Hillary I hope Trump wins on November
they would have put that in there isn't
a single email here from any of these
so-called policemen expressing anything
other than not just the normal
preference that people have for
Democrats or Republicans but in fact
hyper partisan
hyper-partisan further that is actually
preventing them from acting as policemen
and that's what's extraordinary about it
I mean i-i've fell off my chair laughing
I mean maybe it's because I as you can
see I'm in a sinister foreign country
tonight
taco I'm not like Sean Hannity just
hanging out in Singapore I mean I mean
America's sworn enemy the the Dominion
of Canada we're gonna come down and
relaunch the war of 1812 so know me and
me and Justin have been planning it we
were shot by the Inspector General's
report just in Justin's other eyebrow
fell off and he says we got to go down
there and burn the White House all over
again so it's going to be a very tough
pillow fight that's so so so what what
is its pitiful ray today at his press
conference when he was asked why he
fired Peter struck said I well gonna do
this by the book what this report shows
is that there is no book you have the
director of the FBI who thinks that he's
not only the investigative detective but
he's also the prosecutor and the judge
that's not a small mistake that's
devastating you all say then you have
people like people like struck who are
who are investigating a crime the crime
of doing government work on personal
email servers and they're even as
they're investigating that they're doing
government work on email service you
have the most lavishly funded police
agency in the world and the director is
the only guy in Washington who doesn't
know that Anthony Weiner is married to
humor a burden that's absolutely
extraordinary he's the reason he sits on
the the Anthony Weiner pedophile laptop
for a month is that he do I had no idea
she was married to humanity is this
widely known is it in the papers they
were married by Bill Clinton you're the
director this is why why don't you just
yeah you know as I said we're going to
come down and relaunch the war of 1812
you should have the budget they should
be reduced to the budget of some
Moosejaw Police Department and then they
I might be able to figure out whether
you know you who humor evidence married
to the great mark Stein improved even by
your presence in Canada you're helping
that country just by being there mark
Stein great to see you thanks a lot
Turki thank you